[Music]
to look over the horizon and wonder
what's there it's part of what makes us
human even before we were fully human
some 2 million years ago our early
ancestors first left Africa for Asia
long before the age of European
exploration ancient Polynesians in
canoes spread throughout the vast
Pacific Phoenicians mastered the
Mediterranean and Vikings crossed the
Atlantic 500 years ago in 1519 Magellan
set forth on the first successful voyage
to circumnavigate the entire globe and
in the 20th century humans reached the
planets highest peaks and its distant
poles with the invention of the airplane
a new era of exploration was launched
and about a generation after Limburg
flew the Atlantic we reached outer space
and a vast new frontier it was 50 years
ago this summer that Apollo 11 emerged
from a ball of fire streaking towards
the moon with three men on board Neil
Armstrong Buzz Aldrin and Michael
Collins ladies and gentlemen it is my
pleasure to introduce it is your
pleasure to be in his presence the
command module pilot for the Apollo 11
mission Mike Collins
[Applause]
[Music]
super
[Music]
all right Mike it's really it's a great
pleasure to have you here Thank You
miles it's nice to be here too so
magnificent festival yeah it's a good
crowd out there I I will commend every
the astronauts on our program today all
three of them have written books and
with all due respect to the other two
astronauts will be here Mike
wrote the book on writing books on
flying in space his book carrying the
fire which is now back out in print is
is a beautiful eloquent tribute to space
with great technical detail and a great
sense of what the mission is all about
so I recommend you read that and one of
the things you say in your book at the
end which kind of struck me is a mission
like Apollo 11 is a mission that really
never ends here we are 50 years later
you're still talking about it and and
one of the it's a it's a blessing and a
curse in some ways you have to answer
the same questions over and over again
so I need to know right out front what's
your least favorite question that you
get from the likes of me what was it
really like up there what was what
really like up there so Mike what was it
really like up there I it's interesting
that question like you've been holding
out or something yes but having said all
that I know the three of you each have
had a different approach and I'm
speaking of Neil Armstrong and Buzz
Aldrin it there are times when you
prefer not to talk it about it there are
times when you like to what's your
feeling 50 years later now that you've
had a chance to put a little time
between you and the mission how do you
feel about reliving it in some fashion
for people like this well I like to talk
about so many different facets up you
know what's it like up there what does
what specifically but I like to talk I
guess about Neil Armstrong a bit he and
Buzz were remarkable crew members they
were they were just wonderful
Neal was I don't want to say the best of
the bunch but he was the best of the
bunch but we were experimental test
pilots and he was foremost among us
because of his flying experience with
the x-15 rocket ship which still today
holds speed and altitude records he was
a very intelligent man he had wide
breadth of interests far beyond NASA or
the space program centering on history
probably the history of science but
we were very fortunate after the flight
of Apollo 11 to have a round-the-world
trip and Neal was our our spokesperson
at for those occasions and wherever he
went he was a man of few words but he
had chosen them very carefully he knew
the background of the country we were
visiting he knew about a lot about their
people in their country he welcomed
welcomed the audience to come with him
aboard the spacecraft and fly with us
and I I think he did that successfully
and the thing that amazed me about it
was that I thought the reaction would be
wait you Americans finally went to the
moon instead of that it was we did it we
humans we finally got together we did
something that is wonderful we can all
embrace it north-south-east-west
rich-poor everywhere we went the
reaction was we did it and I can't think
of another achievement that has brought
such unanimity of opinion about anything
that we humans do here on earth it's an
amazing irony because it was born out of
Cold War rivalry and in the end instead
of it being we won it was like we all
did it and you get congratulations from
the Soviet Union even that is
extraordinary yes yes I believe it is I
know you talk about this sort of daisy
chain of events and have to occur to
make a mission successful
and there are any number of variables
but in in many cases what NASA does is
has but has redundancy or redundancies
for redundancies but I do know I think
you picked 11 spots along the way of
Apollo 11 where you were most concerned
and one of them is what we're gonna see
a brief clip of right now let's roll the
clip and we'll talk about the
significance of this moment July 19
Apollo 11 slows down and goes into orbit
around the moon the bright blue planet
of Earth now lies 238,000 miles beyond
the lunar horizon astronauts Armstrong
and Aldrin now in the lunar module
separate from the command module
astronaut Collins remains behind
preparation for the lunar module descent
to the moon now begins
so that moment when the lunar module
separated from the command module
Columbia the lunar module being the
eagle and your two crewmates went off
that that was a tense moment and those
that those hours when they were on the
surface were a period of time when you
really sweated the details tell us a
little bit about what was going through
your mind and your concerns actually the
their separation from me and Columbia
and their descent to the landing was not
what was really foremost on my mind I
thought Neal would do a good job he'd
find a smooth nice place to put Eagle
down and although he fiddled and diddled
a little bit on some of the terrain II
considered to be rejectable for one
reason or another he still found a
beautiful landing spot with about 30
seconds of fuel remaining and put it
down this I kind of expected what
worried me was the return we we in NASA
enjoyed machinery that was redundant
usually then we had to love something
not so in the case of the ascent engine
the engine that would bring Neil and
Buzz from the surface back up to me
coming by 60 miles above them that that
just had one one small little combustion
chamber that had to work properly or we
had two dead men on the moon and that
was I think what was foremost on my mind
I had a long list of things to worry
about but I think that was number one
that burned that moment pretty key and
clearly the implications of it not
working were a solo trip back to earth
by you and I assume you thought a little
bit about that you know I did think a
lot about it and I'm sure Neil and Buzz
both thought a lot about it it was
definitely not something we talked about
they knew I knew if if they couldn't get
off for some reason there was nothing I
could do about it I had no landing gear
on Columbia I could not go down and
rescue them I either committed suicide
or came home and and of course
I chose to come home I felt I'd be a
marked man for life really if I'd been
in that situation what do you mean when
you say you'd be a marked man what do
you do you think it would have played
out we don't know too far down that road
but I'm curious well I I think people
would have been sympathetic to my
situation and they would not have been
critical of me but for the rest of my
life they say oh that's that guy you
know who left those two people to die on
their own yeah that would be tough that
would be tough let's uh let's go rewind
the the tape just a little bit and go
back to your early days at NASA you Air
Force fighter pilot and test pilot came
to NASA in class number three you called
yourself the 14 right yeah so were
fourteen of us so it was the first it
was the seventh and the nine and then
the 14 right so this is as they ramped
up toward Apollo and a lot of diversity
in that shot wouldn't you say what do
you think a lot of white male test
pilots in that picture you might say yes
no no I quite agree and then that seems
like an aberration today and it and it
is and in the future should be an
aberration but it wasn't really NASA's
fault it was society's fault and NASA
picked graduates of an experimental test
pilot school only three of those around
so the population available to to NASA
was very limited
for example the NASA recently picked
twelve new astronaut candidates and to
narrow it down to twelve they started
with over 18,000 applications so do your
homework kids
so totally different in my time NASA
picked graduates of experimental test
pilot schools at that time
NASA did not hire women to be
experimental test pilots that there were
one or two black candidates around but
you know within the flood of
applications they they kind of got lost
in it somehow so that's what she ended
up with it was however I defend NASA and
saying they they were not on purpose
selecting white males that was our
Society in those years so the decision
to pick test pilots I guess that makes
sense but they could have gone in other
directions couldn't they yes of course
and they have gone in other directions
and I'm I'm glad they should go in other
directions we were more concerned with
the up and the down getting these new
machines into the air successfully
testing them bringing them back down to
earth and now that we've gone past that
stage and we're in - what are we gonna
do up there what's the science what's
going on why do people want to go what
can they learn and that really has got
very little to do with the upping and
the downing that so obsesses the test
pilot so this I believe is a picture of
you in some of your class doing survival
training because you know god forbid if
there was what we would call a downrange
abort or a landing in a location that
wasn't the ocean near an aircraft
carrier you might have to survive for a
few days in a place like the jungle and
I know you had the great opportunity to
camp out and eat iguana is that right
how was it just like chicken what was
that was the training how much of the
training did you think was kind of nutty
and how much of it was worthwhile well
none of it was out and out nutty some of
it was some of it was had given been
given a great deal of thought in in a
sense of suppose this goes wrong or this
gadget breaks and and that was what we
spent a great deal of our time doing
failure mode
called it but you can take failure modes
to an extreme you know what if this does
well then you fix that but while you're
fixing that the other thing goes wrong
well we've kind of had it real will we
just can't go there we're gonna only
pick one horrible thing at a time and
not try to bunch them all up together
and inevitably the thing that goes wrong
is the thing you didn't think about
right yes yeah what worries you most
about a flight you hit the nail on the
head is that thing that you overlooked
in your training that's what we worried
about so let's talk about your first
mission in space Gemini 10 and by the
way do you to pronounce a Gemini or
Jemma D I've heard in the old days we
used to say Gemini I hear Gemini what do
you go with Monday Wednesday and Friday
I know Gemini and Gemini or Gemini
whatever you prefer and I the great John
Young was your crew mate on that one who
ultimately flew in Gemini Apollo and the
shuttle program for many years flew six
shuttle missions an amazing career at
NASA but your mission on Gemini 10 you
had two spacewalks you're the first guy
to do that and as I understand it there
are we don't have many pictures of that
spacewalk tell us what happened when you
were out there I think you say I lost my
camera that was your yeah this was the
best selfies ever potentially and there
they are they're still floating around
maybe who knows no my job was to leave
the Gemini John was flying it in
formation below fairly close to it maybe
20 25 feet away and I had a little
maneuvering unit a thing called we call
it a gun because it sort of looked like
a little pistol you squirted gas out of
that and that allowed you to propel
yourself and so I had to propel myself
over to the Agena
our target vehicle that had been up
there for months and and from it bring
back an experiment package and return it
to the Gemini and not eventually I did
but I had all kinds of
of things which I in delicately call
maneuvers ass over teakettle at at the
end of a 50-foot umbilical before I was
the second time able to get to where the
package was and bring it
okay back into the Gemini without a
camera and they can't read there today
that must have been slightly
disappointing of course having done the
spacewalk was probably made that a
little easier to go get through let's
talk a little bit about you know we know
so much now fifty years later how little
was known about what you were going to
accomplish you had to rely on all kinds
of simulations we have a picture here of
I believe it's buzz Anil practicing
gathering rocks on the surface of the
moon and I know you spent a lot of time
learning geology that you wish you
didn't have to spend time doing but I do
know this the number of simulations you
did were extremely challenging where you
are talking after all about 1969 with
key punches you know cards going into
computers trying to run simulators
simulators that would crash and so forth
when it came as you got closer to that
July 16th date for launch which was set
by virtue of what the lighting
conditions were gonna be at the landing
site and you had to launch in that time
or wait another month did you guys feel
like you were ready I I'm guessing that
if you gave a crew six months which is
what we had or a year which most of them
had or two years which some of them had
or even longer and later on years I
suppose that irrespective of that the
crew would say well you know I had this
notebook I got 89 things checked off but
I still got 22 to go you never I don't
think fully 100% confident that you know
everything about what is gonna happen or
what might happen or might not happen so
I think
I think most people would feel like they
could use a little extra time and I'm
sure we did also well it's hard to
simulate something that hasn't happened
before you have to there's a lot of
guessing that goes along with that right
in the end do you think the training
match pretty well the simulators were
were extremely accurate based on what we
knew ahead of time some of their
presentations what you saw out the
window were not good at all they were
very crude but in terms of the
duplication of the instrument panels and
more important than that the software
that backed up how those instruments
would record good events bad events
questionable events that aspect of the
simulator training was was crucial to us
and hats off to all the engineers who
put the long hours and in designing
those things so when you think about
what you did the millions of parts
millions of subsystems all from the low
bidder that gave you the Saturn 5 and
the stack which got you to the moon and
back even if it's highly effective and
efficient and and works as planned even
a small percentage that still gives you
thousands of possible failures with that
many systems do you still marvel at how
well it worked I do indeed
those machines are look smooth and nice
and on the outside inside they can be
kind of a nightmare I think in the
command module a design of one switch
one switch alone I believe I had 300 of
those switches presumably I should know
each and every detail about every one of
the 300 clearly I did not but you know I
tried my best to learn a few of them
anyway
it's good to have houston at the other
end of the line isn't it occasionally
you might need them I want to show you
this picture because it you know almost
well every astronaut who goes to space
has this sense of moving forward in the
void but also looking back at the planet
and you of course had this opportunity
to see that which is an extraordinary
and I'm sure you remember the first
moment you saw that happen I'm curious
to what extent did you discover the moon
and to what extent did you discover this
planet on our way to the moon
we didn't look at the moon I know that
sounds strange but we were worried about
the constant sunlight hitting one side
of our spacecraft and making it boiling
and ruining the instrumentation inside
the other side would be minus 400 and
some degrees and everything would freeze
so the solution to that was to turn
sideways to the Sun and rotate slowly
like chicken on a barbecue spit in that
position we could couldn't see the moon
until we got very close to we rolled out
then and looked at it oh my god it was
awesome it was totally different from
that little silver sliver that you see
at night from Earth it filled our whole
window the big window - fairly big
filled a whole window very
three-dimensional it bulges his belly
balls out tortoise the Sun was behind it
and it cascaded all around the rim with
this golden glow which illuminated the
oceans the flat part the Maurya and also
the hilly the craggy part the big and
small craters and it was an awesome
spectacle and wasn't a friendly ones and
didn't say go away but it didn't say
come in either
didn't beckoned but having said all that
having said all that the moon was
nothing compared to the earth earth was
it was the the centerpiece it was all
there was we had an emotional I suppose
a rope attaching us to planet Earth for
whatever reason it was what we wanted to
look at I mean
tiny little thing you could make it go
away by holding your thumb out at arm's
length but if you put your hand down
whoop there it was again and wanted to
be looked at it tiny as I say the blue
and white colors primarily the blue of
our oceans of white of the clouds little
streaks of a kind of a reddish tan
things that we call continents very
shiny very bright very beautiful and and
yet strange though it may seem the
overriding quality well on beauty I
guess I would say but lurking right
behind beauty was a sense of its fragile
it's a fragile little thing out there
the fragility of the earth it was a
response that I never would have
suspected I mean I know it's made out of
rocks month mostly but seemed very
fragile and the more you examine earth
our planet the more you discover that
fragile is not a bad word it is fragile
as it's fragile in thousands of
different ways most of which are not too
good sometimes we humans don't seem like
we really deserve to live on this nice
little thing you see from quarter of a
million miles out I want to pick up on
that theme a little bit later in our
program a bigger that the rest of our
panel but I'm curious about your
thoughts on the space program I know
when you you said that you you made the
decision Apollo 11 would be your last
space find it wasn't like you were
hurrying back to the moon but even in
those days you were like let's go to
Mars
you've been very consistent about that
over the years do you feel that that is
still something that should be a
national priority or for that matter a
global priority to put human beings on
Mars and if so why
well when I came back from Apollo 11 I
used to joke that NASA sent me to their
own place that NASA ought to be renamed
the National Aeronautics and Mars
administration I even wrote a book one
time 20 some years ago mission to Mars
so I'm what I'm about to say is a very
one-sided right now the administration
is backing returned to the moon as a as
a waypoint a jumping-off point for the
planet Mars and and that has a lot of
merit my friend Neil Armstrong was a lot
better engineer than I thought that
there were gaps in our knowledge when we
prepared to go to Mars it would be
useful maybe to stop off at the moon and
learn a few things pick up some of the
knowledge that we didn't have and then
go however I disagree with all the
experts I say that I believe in the John
F Kennedy expressed if I could call it
that Mars direct if we want to go let's
do it let's put our resources into it
let's pick a way of getting there let's
get a schedule let's get the funding
let's get the timing and so on let's go
to Mars
thank you so you I've you're sort of I
would call you the poet laureate of the
Apollo astronauts you you have you're a
very eloquent writer and and you speak
with great authority of course on the
technical detail but you also can
capture what goes on in the right side
of the brain there is an expression of
course NASA has an acronym for
everything and when it comes time for a
spacecraft to go from Earth to moon in
other words fire the rocket and escape
the clutches of Earth's gravity they
call it translunar injection tli kind of
a bore right
tli sorry pronounce it is so so you heat
Mike I know yeah I want to share clip
with people because you were the Capcom
which is the astronaut who speaks to the
the crew in space for Apollo 8 which was
the first crew in history to have a tli
command in other words to leave the the
clutches of Earth's gravity and go
toward the moon and be pulled in by
Earth's gravity it's a momentous moment
let's listen to how this transpired in
Mission Control for a moment if we could
tl i translunar insertion this was the
commitment Borman Lovell and Anders were
ready for the maneuver that would send
them to the moon that was a moment in
history and you said go for tli is that
all I said I mean I thought I thought
the president should be sitting next to
me the Pope would send a message Frank
Sinatra would dedicate a songs and
instead of that I've got some translunar
whatever you said and pl/i and I'm but I
knew I knew down inside that that that
Frank Borman would rise to the occasion
so I was forced by the authorities to
say pilot 11 here go for tli he says
Roger Houston
you know people watching at home might
miss that moment so here we are about 51
years post that moment here's your
moment for a do-over what would you say
if you could do it again oh well I would
have abide by the NASA rules what you
can't you can't say more than I think
eight words in a row and preferably
they're all be monosyllabic but under
those conditions I would say follow
eight the moon is yours go
[Laughter]
that's a good do-over alright Mike
Collins we're gonna bring out the rest
of our panel we're going to move into
still history a little bit but
present-day as well the shuttle ISS era
let's launch into the shuttle era first
liftoff of space shuttle Atlantis
mission to build resupply and to do
research on the International Space
Station
begins its penultimate journey to shore
up the International Space Station
Atlantis now in the proper alignment for
its eight and a half minute line to
orbit
four-and-a-half million pounds of
hardware and humans taking aim on the
International outpost alright let's
bring out our additional panelists first
the former commander of the
International Space Station
the only astronaut with an astronaut
twin the man who has done the longest
stint in space for a u.s. astronaut on
ISS
joining him is the only NASA astronaut
who also played in the National Football
League and a man who somehow was able to
sneak in his two dogs into his official
NASA picture to this day no one knows
how he did it
the coolest astronaut ever
so
I should tell you I I didn't get the
memo on the NASA haircut today I guess
got some scissors we do that right now
why not let's just get it over with now
here's the person you all want to talk
to afterwards because she will get you
to space in the near term she is the
director of astronaut and orbital sales
at Blue Origin Jeff Bezos his company
that is working on all kinds of exciting
things in space
sending tourists to space going to the
moon and maybe someday going to Mars
please welcome Ariane Cornell
okay so Scott as that is the
longest-tenured space traveler all that
time and space we you know we get
glimpses of what it's like up there and
we read your books which they're good
but it's not carrying the fire with all
due respect I agree but nonetheless a
lot of people you know they want to know
just kind of the simple questions like
what it's like up there we see pictures
of you guys playing the food and stuff
and you know spinning around and so
forth what what's the takeaway I know
it's difficult to explain to people if
you haven't been there but what do you
tell them well you know you try to share
the experience with it I'm fortunate
enough to having got the fly in space
four times and spent over 500 days in
space but I'd trade all of that for what
general Colin's got to do here and of
course you know floating it's fun
there's no question about it makes it
but it makes just about everything
harder to do with two exceptions and
that is moving things that are heavy and
also getting your body into weird
positions if you had to like fix
something or you know connect the cable
to the back of the TV but the best part
about it is it's really really
challenging it's a challenging thing to
do to fly in space to live and work in
space and the best part about it is just
that having something that you feel
passionate about working hard at it
doing it as part of a team and then
being successful so Leland would you
agree with what Scott just said about
the idea that a destination would be
more fun than being in orbit in other
words would you trade it all for a trip
to the moon if you could I think I was
fine up to Michael's JFK Express to Mars
definitely yeah I think that destination
piece will will inspire you will
motivate you you get the country behind
it and you do it you just go do it would
you guys do that one-way trip to Mars
that was bandied about a few years back
anybody here would anybody do that
one-way trip to Mars a few you know what
I would do I would do miles yeah is I
would watch that reality show on TV I'm
with you on that one I'm not sure I want
to go with the people who want to go to
Mars one way right there's maybe
something wrong in their lives I'm just
guessing you know there's there's one
thing about traveling in space your best
mission I think is the people that you
fly with it's all about your crewmates
there's kind of a family that's built up
isn't it yeah Mike over the years your
relationship with Buzz and Neil you
write in your book about how your when
you were together you you had so many
things to talk about that were of a
technical nature that you often didn't
get below the surface over the years did
it develop into a closer friendship or
did you maintain sort of a distance from
each other in a way well geography
prevented us being really close all the
time Neyland in Ohio buzz was out in
California mostly I live in Florida but
we tried to stay in touch and as I said
earlier I got to know Neil the best
during our around-the-world trip and I
really came to admire the many facets of
the man and I was so glad that he was
picked to be the first on the moon you
know I was I was shocked by the fact
that for the most important spaceflight
ever they'd only trained together for
six months in a shuttle era that debt
it's unheard of you can think of at
least two years of training right would
be about the norm or the year of anyhow
right
Ariane let's talk about the commercial
component now shuttles gone now eight
years the shuttle was an amazing machine
but it was it was meant to be cheap and
easy access to space that didn't quite
happen as a matter of fact not even
close it was actually pretty dangerous
and expensive and we're in a different
era now what we're thinking about lots
of people going to space what's the big
vision right now is it is it for people
could afford $200,000 or I've heard Jeff
Bezos and and others we won't mention
competitors
but others talk about sending millions
of humans into the cosmos is that it is
that even a realistic notion right now
yes so in fact our vision at Blue Origin
is millions of people ultimately to be
living and working in space that
obviously is not happening tomorrow and
our motto at Goergen is something it's
gradum for asar which in latin means
step by step ferociously and that's how
we're going to approach it and our first
step a Blue Origin is a suborbital
rocket called new shepherd named after
Alan Shepard of course the first
American in suborbital space and by the
end of this year we are going to be
putting a tourists onboard new Shepard
people like you and me are going to be
going up in space initially you know
you're gonna get three to four minutes
of weightlessness so maybe not quite
orbiting the Earth or the moon for that
matter yet but our next plan is new
Glenn a big orbital rocket that's set to
fly in 2021 that it's going to be human
rated and ultimately we will be taking
people to two space stations to the moon
to Mars
you know we're really a destination
agnostic if you will but ultimately we
will be taking many many people to space
so Ariane when you talk about taking
many many people or maybe even one day
millions of people to space what I think
about is what just happened on Mount
Everest and it can get crowded up there
it should can anybody go to space should
everyone go to space and I want to get
the astronauts to weigh in on that too I
mean is there should we set a bar or are
we reaching is it well there one day be
a time when it'll be just as simple as
getting on a commercial airliner well
the latter is our intent I mean you know
with with new Shepard you're gonna be
able to fly to space and what we call a
shirtsleeve environment so literally
what you guys are wearing right now you
come fly on new Shepherd with as in
terms of clothing and the other thing is
that we're trying to open up space for
as many people as possible we want the
training for it even less than six
months it's just gonna be about it
and a half the intent in fact is to make
it so that as many people can go as
possible so it will be like getting on a
commercial airline if you think about
getting on an airplane today you sit
there manufacture on your iPhone even
and the you know the training video is
maybe two minutes we we want we want
this to be we're gonna train you and
make you feel comfortable but we also
want to make be simple and that's that's
important all right astronauts what do
you think okay leave it why don't you go
ahead well I know this is near and dear
to you you guys think about this a lot
because after all you had to go through
a lot of training to go there and it's
nothing to be taken lightly at least as
it is now you know I thought about what
my aha moment would be in space before I
left the planet and I thought it would
be when we install the Columbus
laboratory with the robotic arm because
that was my my job in my primary mission
objective that paled in comparison to
when Peggy Whitson the first female
commander invited us to have a meal in
the Russian segment she said you guys
bring the rehydrated vegetables will
have the meats right she said that
so we float over with this bag of
vegetables we get there and it's African
American Asian American French German
Russian the first female commander going
around the planet every 90 minutes is
17,500 miles per hour and I felt like I
was at home we're breaking bread with
people we used to fight against the
Russians in the Germans and when I
looked out the window at Lynchburg
Virginia my hometown and then I'm
thinking my parents are probably having
meatloaf down there right
five minutes later were over Paris Leo I
hearts is looking down as parents
probably having wine and cheese or
something and URIs looking off at his
parents probably eating borscht in
Moscow so in this very short period of
time we are celebrating all of humanity
as we go around the planet and that
perspective shift that I got was my aha
moment and so if more people if millions
of people can get a chance to go to
space and get this perspective shift
that I got and get this connection back
to the planet I think it will advance
our civilization events our race the
human race so significantly so I opinion
yeah Mike if if I if I've talked to you
in after you got out of quarantine in
August of 69 if I had asked you can you
imagine a day when that scene he just
described happened will happen
Russians Breaking Bad with Americans the
diversity the whole component on a space
station would you have said that was
likely I think it I think it could very
well be III I heart back as I say to
post Apollo 11 around the world trip
everyone saying we did it what color
were they were they male or female who
said we did it who was this we it was
we humankind
got all together believe it or not and
actually agreed on something we did it I
think that's a wonderful moment to
remember into treasure and we can have
that I say world in my window I transfer
that to you world in your window well
what is your world telling you about
these things you can have it you can
have voice in it small but you can have
a voice in it you know I think there can
be a mission profile for just about
anyone and you know the the entry point
would be the suborbital flight and I
think you can probably fly you know
99.9% of the population on that type of
mission now you take that a couple step
further steps further and then you would
have a flight like a shuttle flight and
that would be for you know someone maybe
a little bit more you know extreme
adventure minded person and then living
in space it's you know it's a
challenging place to live and it is not
for everyone but it's for potentially a
lot of people but I think you know in
our future we'll have a lot of different
opportunities for that all of those
collectively would be able to
potentially include most of the
population of the planet so let's talk
about long-duration space travel which
you on this panel have unique insight
into you went to the Space Station for
about a year and this was not just an
endurance test there was a lot of
science associated with this and it
helps the the science is helped by the
fact that you have an identical twin
brother who happens to be or was an
astronaut Mark Kelly who's now running
for Senate by the way in there in
Arizona
yeah got it got a great video
that's what my brother cheering I told
Scott earlier that he could help him on
the campaign trail because who would
know it was him campaigning twice that
twice the campaign power right there so
let's talk about a year in space though
what what there was some science that
was done what was what was the point
what were they trying to get at what did
we not know that we might have learned
by virtue of you being up there for so
long so those people that understand
science and you may be a scientist or
you just you know are interested in it
as a hobby you understand that for an
experiment to be statistically
significant you need a very large sample
so clearly this is a sample of one
there's only one sample and that is my
brother and I comparing me in space with
my brother as the control subject on
earth so the stuff we find from this
experiment which is a bunch of different
things
it's basically considered anecdotal
information it's interesting it's
something that you can look at and then
decide that we need to investigate
further and there were a lot of results
that were surprising you know as an
example might my telomeres and the
telomeres are the ends of our
chromosomes and as we as we age they get
shorter and more afraid it's basically
basically an indication of our physical
age and the hypothesis was me in space
you know the radiation challenging
environment stress or whatever my
telomeres would get shorter compared to
my brothers on earth well they actually
got
now some people thought that they
improved because of the you know the
restricted diet your on exercise you
know a very controlled schedule maybe
but recently I found out there were also
some worms on the space station that
their telomeres actually improved as
well and the fact that I never saw them
exercising and also the fact that mine
went back to normal pretty soon after I
got back means there's some kind of
genetic thing going on that we don't
quite understand I also had some you
know 7% of my gene expression had
changed during the course of the year so
there are some genetic things we need to
look at further and investigate further
I think as part of our air plan to send
people to Mars some day yeah I'm just
you know heart back just a few years
before that on Gemini we were just
amazed we thought we were really
reaching out we thought we'd reach maybe
the limit we sent two people up for 14
days I don't think you'd unpacked in 14
but if you've taken a look at a Gemini
spacecraft 14 days in a Gemini versus a
year and an ISS I don't know I might be
might have been a harder mission yeah
for those two that and they they at very
little room yeah but let's go back to
that side one more time because it talks
about your cognition how is your
cognition anyway you seem to be doing
okay tonight yeah you know a lot of
people focused in on the fact that when
I got back my cognition declined I
pretty much improved throughout the
mission and I think that's a function of
you know the longer you're in space the
more comfortable you feel you I never
actually felt normal
I don't think anyone would ever feel
completely normal you always have the
fluid shift your head on the ISS Co twos
even when it's at its lowest
so hi the co2 bothered um yeah and you
can feel it
I could tell within you know a tenth of
a millimeter what it was and I think of
look and see that I was I was pretty
accurate so you know throughout the
mission you're feeling better never
perfect you're doing these tests over
and over so you're getting better at
them so I think that was why my
cognition got better and then when I got
back I don't really think it was a like
a cognition deficit I had I think it was
more the fact that I just didn't feel
well when I got back from Earth back to
earth and when you don't feel well like
imagine going to take the SAT if you had
the flu you probably wouldn't do well
that's kind of I think why they saw a
decline that was noticeable when I got
back it's just a function of how tired I
was and physically did not so let me the
straight there's co2 Rises you get
cranky and you don't feel well so you
were kind of a lab rat for the future of
climate change in some respects uh tell
you what you know when like I said with
co2 at its lowest it's ten times what it
is on earth on this on the space station
sometimes it's thirty times so we're at
like four hundred and fifteen parts per
million it's thirty 30 times that right
that's just that's amazing yeah Wow Wow
well it's ten times what it is okay ten
at its lowest on the ISS and it is not
comfortable and that's just because they
want to save the machines they could
dial in so it's a little easier on you
but yeah you know it's a it's partly
resources problems you know you you
don't want to use all your spare parts
when the you know the supply chain is
not reliable some finest things blow up
it's hard to get to the home depot Leela
now you also spent a good deal of your
time as an astronaut in in Washington
but not a lot of space flights there but
a lot of engagement with young people
and you you headed the education office
for a time I'm curious what your
thoughts are having had that experience
of being in space and then and trying to
reach out to young people look many of
whom are in this audience the value of
space as a way to inspire young people
look
teach them about things like climate
change and co2 for example or little
things like that or or what it's like to
be in space or telomeres for that matter
how much value is there in that I think
it's extremely valuable because it's one
of those things where I will go into a
classroom and the kids love dinosaurs
and space and so if you can if you can
genetically make a dino not you'd be
golden right you know the reason I have
in my blue flight suit I got the memo to
wear the jacket but lots of times you
know I got something on Facebook from a
mother Kelly out there somewhere who's
bringing her eight-year-old son here to
see this and the suit for a lot of kids
and communities that I go into but never
imagined even thinking about going to
space and certain zip codes didn't we
know what an astronaut is but I walk
into that neighborhood with this on and
they ask the question what is that where
did you go who designed that and that
starts the exploration and I think once
we you know once we have their interest
just a little bit then you can start
changing the way they think their
mindset about what they can do with
their lives and representation
it truly does matter Michael you talked
about earlier about how diverse that
picture was not those original people
and how we've changed now in this day
and age of who were sending to space and
who's representing you know the future
of humanity and I think education is one
of the things that you can get a kid
inspired my mother gave me a chemistry
set when I was probably in middle school
that was agent appropriate non OSHA
certified and I created the most
incredible explosion in her living room
burned a hole in her carpet
initially had a hand in my development
you know my brain was active
majored in chemistry while playing
football in college because of that one
intervention so if we can find it
using the space station using Legos on
the space station going to Mars and then
kids see that they can get to Mars it's
this that's the way using space as a
tool let's talk a little bit more about
the commercialization of space first of
all the Blue Origin is just part of a
big picture here you've flown 11 times
now let's take a look at the most recent
launch which was earlier in a first part
of May right let's watch it
[Music]
so this rocket this is new Shepard the
the capsule on the booster liftoff
together and about 75 kilometres the
capsule separates from the booster and
you go over long kilometers so that view
there's that's the beautiful view you
guys are gonna be seeing when you're up
in space the booster comes back down to
land because we reuse the rocket and
then the capsule itself comes down under
three parachutes and just the last
second we have a retro thrust amor
basically like an air cushion that gives
you a nice soft landing
we've also you saw in that film we've
done quite a few extreme tests on the
vehicle to what we say as we say test
the corners of this system to make sure
it can work in emergency situations or
in in awful we call off nominal
situations and we're getting very close
to flying people we're gonna be putting
people on top of that rocket at the end
of this year you want to come flying
with me excellent so when you say soon I
know it's hard to pin ting are we
talking about a year or less than a year
from now what are you thinking so we our
aim is to put people on this rocket by
the end of the year and so we had
another as miles mentioned the last
flight was in May it was the smoothest
to date we are we are really hitting our
stride but most importantly we are not
going to fly people until until the
entire team is ready and we feel that
we've we've got a handle on the system
but we're getting close I I would jump
on that rocket tomorrow if given the
opportunity we you know some of the
tests you saw there we have an escape
motor in the capsule we've tested it on
ground we've tested it what we call max
Q or the most aerodynamically intense
moment on the rocket performed perfectly
we performed up at max altitude I mean
things are going very well on the system
so so it's not just about flying
tourists however I know Jeff Bezos
vision is much grander than that and he
also just with them and I think the past
month or so announced his there's Lander
would go to the Blue Moon which would go
to the moon tell us about blue moon and
what his goals are there I was
this same NASA meeting I was at this
morning there was a lot of talk about
Blue Moon as being part of the
architecture of NASA's renewed interest
in going to the moon sooner because they
don't have a lander and this project has
been going on for a little while it -
you guys - still you're kind of secret
about your projects generally but let's
look at what blue moon looks like and
why don't you explain what the potential
missions might be for it of course so
what you're seeing here so this is blue
moon our lunar lander the intent with
this this craft is to take about 3.6
metric tons to the lunar surface and
eventually 6.5 metric tons on the way to
the surface of the moon we can also
deploy small satellites and some other
scientific craft to take data and then
the blue moon itself will land on top of
bloom of the blue moon lander we can
take Rovers we can take other craft and
and place them onto the lunar surface so
this this our blue moon program fits
perfectly into the administration's
plans to land on the moon by 2024 we've
been at it for the last three years
which is why we can we could jump to
such an aggressive timeline where we're
ready and and one of the you know I was
talking about earlier gradum for
Rossiter step by step ferociously one of
the reasons why we're going to be doing
this or we're able to do this is that
we've taught ourselves how to land
rockets here on earth which has six
times as much gravity as up on the moon
so we there are systems that we've been
working on for a while that's going to
enable blue moon so there is a little
bit of confusion about this when you get
into this idea of commercial space
because the truth of the matter is nASA
has never built a rocket there has
always been a contractor in the mix and
it's just how the contracts are
structured NASA in this case might buy a
service get me to the surface and back
whereas in the days when you were you
know shepherding through that that
command module you were in on the
factory floor every week making sure
everything was connected in the right
way what are the pros and cons of that
on the one hand it sounds like that
would be safer
you're really paying attention to how
the craft is built on the other hand you
have less visibility and/or how it is
built what are your thoughts on it bike
is is it inherently safer to do it the
way you did it back in the 60s I don't
know about the safety but I don't think
a dollar bill knows whether it's a
federal dollar bill or or a commercial
dollar bill I don't know how you can say
no to the overtures of Jeff besos and
and some others to put part of their
private funds to add those to the
federally appropriated kitty and you can
do more and more than you can with less
and I welcome aboard
I think it's wonderful yeah Scott would
you have any hesitation flying on
whether it's a you know a Blue Origin
craft or a SpaceX craft to the space
station or perhaps beyond would you do
it I would have hesitation flying on
anything which is appropriate right it
is very risky you know as we get more
experienced it becomes less risky so I
would want to learn about the rocket
understand the systems the redundancy
but I think you know I could I would
probably having done that absolutely fly
on a Blue Origin or SpaceX rocket I mean
they I've been to Blue Origin I've been
to spacex they those two companies both
does seem very very professional very
talented people but yeah I wouldn't just
jump on without understanding it because
I want to come back I like her
it's gonna say we're not building this
in a vacuum but that it has a different
context you know we we are you know as
people we are standing on shoulders of
giants they're sitting on this stage
with me believe it or not I'm having a
hard time believing it but it's we have
we worked very closely with NASA we take
a lot of lessons learned from decades
past at blue we have a really nice mix
of veterans who've been in the industry
for decades
astronaut NASA astronauts I've got three
veteran NASA astronauts working at blue
including the head of the new Shepherd
program so we and we also have those
that are coming out of out of university
so we've got this really nice balance
because we really really do believe that
this company and these these projects
are gonna be around for a while so we we
are building a system that's going to be
the the workhorse for the American space
industry for decades to come but the
only way that we can do that is with
really good relationships with NASA and
with with those that have done it in the
past Leland how about you any
hesitations I think the the rewards
outweigh the risk when I when I went to
space on the shuttle you know was the
lowest bidder right I I got there and I
undid my seat belt and I floated over to
the window and I looked out and I was
looking at the Caribbean ocean and I
needed new definitions of the color blue
to describe what I saw and that also
fundamentally changed me and if we can
get more people to share that experience
back you know back to the planet you'll
get more energy around exploring you'll
get more kids excited you'll get more
people doing things working together as
one humanity and that's how it's worth
it to me to take the risk Mike I know
when you were orbiting the moon you
radio down at one point or maybe you're
on your way back but you said something
to the effect I wish you know several
hundred million Americans could have
this experience with me how do you think
that would change life on Earth I know I
don't think he don't think you have to
go to the moon I'd go up
pick the hundred miles is a nice orbital
I mean you're above all that friction
stuff there and you've got the the
Communists and the capitalists and
they're side by side looking out a
window hell they can't even find their
own country much less say that one is
better than that one I think it would in
subtle ways really change way political
leaders think about their their own turf
and other people's if it if you can
divide turf into theirs and ours how do
you how you deal with things on a
unified global basis I think it would
help my my guy called my Russian brother
from another mother Mikhail Kornienko
Misha my guy spent nearly a year in
space he would sometimes say on the
space station when we were there you'd
say you know if our two countries wanted
to solve any differences solve the
problems we have with one another all we
need to do is put our two presidents and
space together for a year
[Laughter]
legally this idea it's been written
about quite a bit this idea of it's
called the overview effect there is some
something that changes when people have
this ability to is that real what is it
about it is there something that really
changes the way you view life it when
you get back down on terra firma or is
it just a fleeting moment in space and
you're back to your everyday life well
before I went to space I was driving
down I was driving from Houston down so
you clearly go on highway 45 and this
driving my car and this guy in this big
pickup truck with the big mirrors and
the dually cuts me off and I probably
say some things I probably should have
said and then the same thing happened
but this time I was driving from Clear
Lake to to Houston after flying in space
and I just said to myself dude you can't
hurt me
I've been his face and I had and I do
feel like I mean Frank white what a book
about this of the overview effect and
it's a cognitive shift that people get
when they see the planet from this
vantage point I feel like there was
something cognitively that changed in me
especially when I was breaking bread
with Peggy and the rest of the team over
there in the Russian segment and it did
feel like something you know
fundamentally changed now did you did
you feel that oh yeah of course you know
and I would describe it a little bit
more you know when you look at the earth
you don't see any political borders when
you look at the Earth from space not
like we expect to see it on a map you
think of Earth in terms of you know
before you've flown in space you think
of how you view it on a map with
political borders
of course you know you could see those
at night with the lighting in different
countries but during the daytime you
don't you see an incredibly beautiful
planet you know because you follow the
news that there are a lot of bad things
that go on on a daily basis on planet
Earth and these are problems that are
solvable when you're on the space
station there's hundred billion dollar
space station probably one of the
hardest things we have ever done if we
can do that you recognize we can you
know do other things to help humanity
the other thing you notice is just how
fragile the atmosphere is it looks like
a thin film over the surface of the
earth when we're on the ground you look
up the sky looks infinite when you're in
space I remember one of my first days in
space I was like what is that film and
then you realize that is our atmosphere
just where all the pollutants are going
into you know there's some parts of the
earth almost always covered with
pollution parts of Asia I think you know
kids in those countries if you ask them
what color the sky was they probably say
brown or gray you know the rainforest in
South America I noticed a very very
obvious change between my first flight
in 1999 my last in 2016 you know fires
over certain parts of the
continent's you you see the effect of
people that have how people affect this
planet which is incredibly beautiful but
also incredibly fragile I think we
talked about fragility of the planet but
I and I hear what you both of you have
said about the fragile Oasis but I I
think that it's not that the planet's
fragile they said we are screwing it up
and that we're gonna be burped out and
the planet will be resilient and all fix
itself later so we're we're doing it to
the planet and doing it to ourselves
yeah and it's you know it's gonna be us
so really the the reason why blue is so
focused on these reusable rockets we
talked about is to access the resources
of space but it really is to help earth
so it's bringing the resources down but
ultimately part of our grander vision is
how how do we get heavy industry off the
planet how do we get these pollutant
elements and industries off and maybe
use earth just for residential and maybe
some light industry space has a lot of
it might sound far-off but the moment
that we're gonna hit that that oh oh
gosh moment it's going to be too late to
work on technologies that are going to
be necessary to get us up there and get
back and bring resources back and get
some of these again infrastructure up
into space to help us here on earth
there should not be a plan B we've been
to every single one of the planets and
this one by far is the best so we ought
to do what we can to keep this one copy
and healthcare
so Mike I know you've had similar it's
had a similar effect on you and made you
very concerned about the environment
tell us a little bit about how your view
of the earth that earth rise and being
able to cover up everything you know
with your thumb how that changed you as
you lived out the the last 50 years not
hadn't changed me enough I haven't done
a particularly good job in the last 50
years of putting my my footprints or my
my bank account where my money is I mean
where my mouth is I think we can I don't
think I'm rare in that I mean we I think
we talk a good game
I'm not sure we play a good game i I
certainly have not I I pursue my own
hobbies and whatnot without really
giving consideration of a sufficient
consideration to the fragility and and
and of course you're absolutely right
about the is it really fragile or weak
fragile people living on a rock not sure
that matters something is fragile my
system is fragile and I certainly worry
about that the word fragility just
floats in and out of my head whether I
want it or not isn't that what you're
writing about right now though tell us a
little bit about it I'm writing a book
number five it's a series of essays and
one of them touches on what we're
talking about which is a world
population well what should the world
population be ken zombie is anyone
working on trying to find an answer to
that I don't think so that's you know
there are organizations international
organizations but they write learning
papers that they pass back and forth
between half a dozen people and and
there are their conclusions don't ever
seem to reach the politicians when we
flew to the moon the world population
was two billion and now it's I think
around eight predictions are it's going
to fairly soon be ten
and is is that sensible is that okay
well maybe I don't think so however but
but my main point is not whether I think
it's too big too small or just right but
that no one is paying the attention to
it the nation should pay and it's an
extraordinarily difficult problem
because we all know the diversity of
north-south wanted factor after another
but somehow we have to get all these
competitive countries together to try to
at least plan on where are we going well
what do we want it to be next fiscal
year ten fiscal years whatever I think
we should be working the problem and
we're not kind of kind of peril and
promise that the promise is a lot of the
excitement we we hear here and how space
can help us in ways but it does space at
some point become frivolous and a waste
or will it always be some means towards
solving problems here I think the latter
but I've you know I might might be a bit
biased on that but no I mean you were
you are literally looking into infinity
right this image that you're looking
here the amount of resources that we can
that we can access and use and enhance
you know if we're looking at a altima
population cap we're walking towards
stasis that's sad humanity is supposed
to expand is supposed to evolve I mean
how you know think about things just
plateauing or even going backwards that
seems yeah that just makes me sad I
think we we will continue to look to
space and what it has to offer for our
future
Scott how important is space in the
picture when you think about the
problems we have here on the ground so I
you know for one it's a technology
accelerator I don't I don't you know I'm
out of not a believer that if it wasn't
for Apollo we wouldn't have cellphones
right now or the key would enough
computers but I think space food sticks
and tank for
and we do have the space ice cream which
actually like that we got that in space
better than not but yeah so I think you
know doing the hardest thing we can do
requires us to develop technologies to
do that and I think that improves our
lives here on earth I also agree that we
are explorers and as soon as we stop
exploring and we look inward we're
probably not going to exist for very
much longer I think that is part of our
DNA to always want to see what is over
the horizon whether that's the horizon
of of the ocean or the horizon of the
moon or eventually Mars but if you made
the argument that everything I just said
was wrong and the only thing we got out
of spaceflight is that kids in this
country or around the world were
motivated to become scientists and
engineers to do their homework to work
in fields that are incredibly important
to our our economy incredibly important
to our national security if the
investment alone just got us motivated
and moving in in a positive direction
towards developing scientists and
engineers I think every penny is well
worth the expense and the and the last
thing is you know I spent over 500 days
on the International Space Station
there's no money there all that money
was spent on Earth you know with people
and with high-paying jobs good jobs
people that then you know go on to pay
their taxes to send their kids to
college so I think it's an investment in
our future in you know many many
different ways Leland would you go along
with it I agree with Scott and I I just
think that this the this marring of us
in our DNA to explore is one of the
biggest things that we do with space
whether it's the oceans or space and
when I was interviewed to become an
astronaut there were 2,500 people that
applied I was one of 25 US astronauts
chosen
and right before I was chosen John Young
turned to me and he said Leland if we
stop exploring who will falter as a
civilization and so I believe John Young
and I know that if we stop doing this
we're gonna die as a civilization the
other thing is you know what Scott you
just said I had a chance to talk to a
kid when he was 16 years old at the Jet
Propulsion Laboratory where in this blue
flight suit and I gave a commencement
speech at George Mason and this young
guy walks up to me he says hey do you
remember me I'm getting my PhD in
aerospace engineering because you told
me that I could if we can do this maybe
that kids not gonna find space maybe
they're gonna cure cancer or maybe
they're gonna get in some other field
and build your rockets or something but
this hope this inspiration this
leadership is something that I think we
have to do whether wherever the
exploration goes we must explore should
we go back to the moon should we press
toward Mars how much does that matter if
it's about inspiring young people is it
well any mission do I think I think
going to Mars is showing I mean what
President Kennedy said back in the day
it's because we do the things that are
hard and we've been to the moon we've
demonstrated that do we need to have a
lunar base as it is a launch pad to get
us to Mars I don't think so
but if we decide to do this as a
civilization as a people let's put the
money up there and do it and go do it
just like Kennedy did what do you know
there well there I think there are
probably some teenagers in here and I
don't know if you guys are aware of this
stand by stand up teenagers but all
teenagers said yeah the Mars
I don't know if you realize this but but
you guys have never been on the earth
with all the people your whole lives
there there has always been people in
space and I think one of the things we
should make a commitment to is never
changing that I think no matter what we
do and someday we will have to put the
International Space Station or at least
parts of it in the in the Pacific Ocean
I think we should make a commitment to
always having people in space and at
least that keeps us moving in the
positive in a positive direction you
know someday we're gonna go to Mars I
hope I get to see it I hope you guys get
to do it maybe we should go back to the
moon I think that's a choice depending
on really about how much money you have
to invest but I think the planet needs
to make a commitment to always have
people in space we got a 20 year record
don't want to break it the panel
starting with Ariane paint the vision 50
years from now when we come back and do
this event again and we'll all be here
what will we be where will we be in
space you think what's your prediction
uh I mean I think that I think that
they're gonna be a lot more people in
space I think that's going to be driven
by the improvements in reusable rockets
that are gonna be able to get people and
again you know space stations or other
sorts of heavy infrastructure up there
and I think it's going to as we're
seeing here a touch a lot more people's
lives
through various elements of space
technology whether it's people actually
getting up into space or then being able
to benefit from the technology that's
coming from space will there be millions
by 50 years or that was in zero
I don't think necessarily millions that
vision of millions of people living and
working in space you know is it my
grandchildren is it your grandchildren
or their grandchildren we'll see we'll
see and in fact I think frankly the
future is is to be written by them so we
can predict all day but it's the young
people in the audience and
and you notice the future generations
that are gonna make they're gonna paint
the picture all right
Leland 50 years from now 50 years from
now I inspired these students had stood
up these kids have stood up a lot of
these kids don't see race and don't see
color and don't see isms so I am very
hopeful that in 50 years some of those
kids will be orbiting Mars working
together as close-knit teams with their
friends and family and people from all
around the planet
I think it's possible if we as a society
decide that this is important and you
know my experience on the space station
working with people from around the
world it changed me and I think they're
already changed in the things that they
do and the tweeting and texting and I
Jing and all of this connectivity even
though sometimes a little too much but
but they will make it there and we'll be
in Mars whether it's on the planet or
orbiting its Mars Scott well I agree
mostly with what my two colleagues here
just said and if you consider the fact
that we went from flying an airplane for
the first time in 1903 and then general
Collins here and Neil and Buzz stepped
foot on the moon on Apollo 11 was that
66 years later I mean if you think about
that you know advancement in technology
and just barely over 50 years what are
our potential is now whether we you know
use that potential to create a space
industry that is vibrant that have have
a lot of people having access to space
to going back to the Moon and Mars I
don't know you know if you consider the
fact that they're gonna be people in the
US Air Force flying the b-52 that's
gonna be a hundred years old at one
point people will be flying a
hundred-year-old
airplane in the US Air Force nothing
against the b-52 but I mean you can see
how you can sometimes just kind of get
stuck and keep doing the same thing and
I hope we don't wind up there
Mike will end it with you I want to
modify the question you have a two-part
you have a bonus question in addition to
the question I've asked everybody else I
want to ask have you first answer if I
asked you the same question
50 years ago what would you have said no
I don't want to answer that one I want
to I want to say was fifty years from
now we'll break okay and you get to do
what you want and I I don't know I
haven't a clue but I think you will
figure it out
I think young people today are smarter
there's you guys are men and women black
white whatever you're smarter than I am
you'll figure it out you you haven't
you're working from a bigger database
part of that thanks to the space program
most of it not but you'll you'll work it
out I'm very optimistic that your future
that you will chart as time goes by is
better than the future that I would
perhaps predict right now good place
ended Mike Collins Scott Kelly Leland
Melvin Aaron Cornell
[Music]